parteitag in dresden die alternative für
deutschland will sich geeint zeigen und
vertagt erst einmal die wahl von
spitzenkandidaten für den bundestag
medikamente gegen cupid 19
forscher fordern dafür mehr
unterstützung um die korona ins kampagne
besser zu ergänzen tragödie fernab der
weltöffentlichkeit die abgeschottete
diktatur nordkorea kämpft wohl mit einer
gewaltigen hungersnot
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten den samstag sport
hat norbert lehmann dabei ein tor von
mir
wer soll die afc in die bundestagswahl
führen das war die spannende frage vor
dem großen parteitag in dresden 570
mitglieder versammelten sich da in
präsenz für parteichef wollten ein
klares statement gegen diese so wörtlich
verbots orgien dieses einsperren diesen
lockdown wahnsinn
die alternative für deutschland will als
anti verbots partei in den wahlkampf
ziehen
die frage der spitzenkandidatur zuerst
einmal vertagt christiane hübscher ein
fdp-parteitag bisher ganz ohne eklat
überwiegend mit masken und mit abstand
will die zerstrittene partei vor allem
ein signal aus dresden senden
demonstrative geschlossenheit die
innerparteilichen kleinkriege der
letzten monate sind wasser auf die
mühlen unserer politischen gegner
schluss mit dem lagerdenken schluss mit
den skiern und schranken im kopf
jetzt ist schluss damit es reicht dabei
hätten einige co-parteichef leuten heute
gerne vorzeitig abgewählt der antrag
schafft es gar nicht erst auf die
tagesordnung der richtungsstreit aber
bleibt bundesvorsitzende
augenscheinlich nicht integrieren kann
und nicht integrieren will sondern der
leider schweizerisch tätig ist und uns
schadet wenn dann einige hier oder da
immer noch dieses dieses märchen
verbreiten sollten
ich wollte das spalten oder etwaiges
dann müsste spätestens heute der letzte
eines anderen belehrt sein das ist
einfach unfug mehrere landesverbände
beantragen die spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl gleich hier und heute zu
wählen
pofalla gilt dafür als gesetzt alles
weitere will zumindest auf dem parteitag
nicht kandidieren
dafür meldet die hessinnen joanna krupa
ihr interesse an
doch es kommt nicht zur wahl es bleibt
dabei die basis soll das spitzenduo per
urwahl bestimmen ich glaube dass wir uns
zunächst intern beraten müssen wer in
welchem team überhaupt antritt
und ob ich selbst antrete das kann ich
ihnen heute noch nicht beantworten auch
wenn jetzt der parteitag das entschieden
hätte hätte sich die basis die wir
gefühl das kann man nicht machen
insofern finde ich die entscheidung
richtig und so bleibt der fc in dresden
wohl nur ihr programm für die
bundestagswahl zu beschließen
der slogan der kampagne deutschland aber
normal keine streitereien mehr schluss
mit dem lagerdenken das scheint man das
motto der afg zu sein
wie verlässlich ist diese neue
geschlossenheit den nicole diekmann
das ist ein äußerst brüchiger
burgfrieden denn er entspringt eben
nicht dem ende des in der afg fast schon
traditionellen lagerdenkens sondern
reinem pragmatismus auf dem letzten
parteitag hat afg chef j leuten die
eigene leute zum teil sehr scharf
angegriffen
und darauf folgte offener selbst für afg
verhältnisse bitterer streit
hinzu kommt eine nach wie vor drohende
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
und die wahlschlappen in rheinland pfalz
und baden württemberg haben und auch
nicht gerade zur beruhigung beigetragen
auf die frage woher nun diese neue
friedfertigkeit führe sagte
fraktionschef bauland denn auch
lediglich einen satz wir wollen wahlen
gewinnen und dann delegierter hier
ergänzte wir haben heute zwar den graben
zugeschüttet aber die tretminen darunter
die sind noch da
vielen dank für die einordnung nicole
diekmann in berlin
die union hatte sich bis pfingsten zeit
gegeben um ihren kanzlerkandidaten zu
wählen eigentlich doch jetzt scheint der
druck immer größer zu werden die frage
laschet oder so schnell zu entscheiden
führende unionspolitiker warnten davor
auf ein pfingstwunder zu hoffen man
brauche möglichst bald klarheit auch für
die nächste landtagswahl in sachsen
anhalt fahren wir ja unterleib energy in
berlin
morgen soll es ja in einer art in einer
klausur eine art schaulaufen der beiden
kandidaten aus cdu und csu geben könnte
sich da schon etwas entscheiden
ja wenn man auf die art der
veranstaltung guckt dann hat man schon
den eindruck dass es so etwas wie das
finale vorsingen im wettbewerb ist es
geht bei dieser klausursitzung um das
zukunftsprogramm der union
am vormittag wird angela merkel sprechen
danach laschet und söhne haben also
beide da die möglichkeit ihre ideen noch
einmal vorzutragen
aber man muss auch dazu sagen das ganze
ist nicht als entscheidungsrunde gedacht
weil es ein kleiner kreis ist da tag nur
der geschäftsführende fraktionsvorstand
das sind ein gutes dutzend zweiter grund
zwar gut zwei dutzend menschen die da
sitzen
und deswegen ist eine entscheidung
morgen unwahrscheinlich trotzdem steigt
der druck immer mehr namhafte
cdu-politiker melden sich zu wort und
sagen jetzt muss es mehr tempo geben bei
der kanzlerkandidatenfrage volker
bouffier hat heute eine art und wartung
gestellt
im interview mit der frankfurter
sonntagszeitung sagt er innerhalb der
nächsten woche sollte man sich
entscheiden ansonsten könnten auch die
partei präsidien den weg zur
entscheidung aufzeigen also das gibt
noch mal ordentlich druck zusätzlich und
50 cdu bundestagsmitglieder haben sich
zu wort gemeldet und haben gesagt auch
sie möchten gerne mitreden das ist
immerhin ein viertel der
cdu-bundestagsabgeordneten die möchten
eine diskussion und im zweifel auch eine
entscheidung über die
kanzlerkandidatenfrage innerhalb der
fraktion also die nervosität in der
union steigt die spannung auch vielen
dank und hella donna und den
neuinfektionen es heißt ja wegen der
feiertage seien die zahlen nur bedingt
belastbar
es zeichnet sich aber ein anstieg auf
bereits hohem niveau
das lka meldet 24 1097 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages das sind knapp 6000
mehr als am vergangenen samstag 246
menschen starben in verbindung mit coop
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
steigt auf 120,6 die zahl der
infizierten steigt also und mit ihr die
zahl der schweren krankheitsverläufe
doch noch immer fehlt ein wirksames
medikament gegen korona die tu
braunschweig steht hier nach eigenen
angaben kurz vor dem durchbruch
doch um vom labor in die praxis zu
kommen brauchen die forscher innen geld
und setzen dabei auch auf die
bundesregierung morgen über die neue
hoffnung aus braunschweig hier an der
technischen universität braunschweig
haben sie ein antikörper medikament
gegen korona entwickelt mit
unterstützung von akademischen
institutionen die helmholtz zentrum und
fraunhofer institut in rekordzeit wurde
die klinische studie zu belassen eine
menge hoffnung steckt in diesen winzig
kleinen mengen klarer flüssigkeit das
medikament hilft den menschen mit dem
virus umzugehen indem es ihn einfach
blockiert das heißt wenn viren vorhanden
sind können sie ihnen nicht noch kranker
machen
wir haben in unseren versuchen zb
beobachtet dass der antikörper die
viruslast in der tiefen lunge mehr als
99 prozent verringert innerhalb von
wenigen tagen eine hohe wirksamkeit im
laborversuch noch in diesem monat wird
das medikament bykow wird kranken
eingesetzt in sechs testzentren in
deutschland doch den forschern und dem
braunschweiger unternehmen kurat
therapeut iks geht nun das geld aus
klinische studien sind teuer
50 millionen bräuchte das junge
biotech-unternehmen um weiterzumachen
das land niedersachsen hat bereits
investiert vom bund gab es bisher noch
nicht
es ist auch so dass wir aktuell die
problematik haben das mittlerweile ein
chinesischer staatsfonds vor der tür
steht und bereit wäre entsprechend dann
halt auch die finanziellen mittel zur
verfügung zu stellen ich bin der ansicht
dass wir deutsche errungenschaften
respektive auch forschungsergebnisse
entsprechend dann auch hier halten
sollten griff
pentax hat gerade zusammen mit 13
anderen abgeordneten einen brief an die
kanzlerin geschrieben
sie soll die finanzielle beteiligung von
corona medikamenten zur chefsache machen
die politik habe viel zu lange nur aufs
impfen gesetzt kritisieren experten
es fehlt immer noch an wirksamen
medikamenten gegen korona besonders bei
mittleren und schweren verläufen genau
auf die ist die antikörper-therapie der
braunschweiger konzipiert vor einem
schweren krankheitsverlauf schützt auch
die impfung
und die soll es bald auch für
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren geben
piontek und pfizer haben in den usa eine
notfall zulassung beantragt der
gemeinsam entwickelte impfstoff zeigte
nach angaben der hersteller auch bei den
probanden zwischen 12 und 15 jahren eine
hundertprozentige wirksamkeit us
präsident joe biden wollte vieles anders
machen als sein vorgänger aus seiner
sicht besser vor allem beim thema
einwanderung statt abschottung versprach
er einen liberalen humanen kurs doch
genau dieser anspruch holt ihn nun ein
immer mehr menschen strömen an die
grenze im süden darunter auch
alleinreisende kinder und jugendliche
19.000 waren es im märz so viele wie
noch nie
untergebracht werden sie in
auffanglagern ines trams frühmorgens im
grenzgebiet zwischen den usa und mexiko
kinder und jugendliche migranten
aufgegriffen von us grenzschützern der
übergang ist dicht für erwachsene
so schicken viele eltern ihre kinder
allein auf den weg oft mit der hilfe von
schleppern diese schlepper laden sie auf
ein schlauchboot bringen sie über den
fluss und setzen sie dann hier ab sie
sagen nur da geht's richtung norden dann
holen sie die nächste gruppe immer hin
und zurück
schlepper lassen zwei mädchen vom
grenzzaun fallen erschreckende bilder
einer überwachungskamera
grenzschutzbeamten retten die beiden
schwestern im alter von drei und fünf
jahren aus ecuador unbegleitete junge
migranten landen im gefängnis ähnlichen
auffanglagern wie diesem in donna texas
minderjährige schiebt präsident biden
nicht ab doch die neue us regierung ist
nicht vorbereitet es fehlt an
unterkünften und pflegefamilien ein
mädchen beispielsweise kam hierher damit
ihr onkel sie aufnimmt ich fragte sie
weißt du wo du hin willst in welchem
bundesstaat sie sagte ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß nur es schneit dort es ist eine
feuerprobe für beiden er weiß er muss
die situation an der grenze schnell
beruhigen die republikaner
instrumentalisieren das thema
einwanderung eine delegation von ihnen
zu besuch an der grenze sie sprechen von
einer krise für das land und die
migranten
es ist falsch es ist eine form von
kindesmissbrauch all das hätte nicht
passieren dürfen es ist eine
selbstverschuldete wunde eine künstliche
krise herbeigeführt von präsident biden
im märz kamen knapp 19.000 minderjährige
migranten über die grenze so viel wie
noch nie in einem monat und die zahl sie
wächst aus nordkorea kommen derzeit töne
die mehr als ungewöhnlich sind
der machthaber spricht fast offen über
das leid in seinem land vergleicht die
aktuelle situation sogar mit der
tödlichen hungersnot in den 90er jahren
nordkorea ohnehin abgeschottet ganz
besonders jetzt in der pandemie
unabhängige informationen gibt es
praktisch nicht klar scheint die armut
in der bevölkerung ist enorm
der diktator selbst nennt die lage jetzt
die schlimmste in der geschichte
ulf röller der auftritt wirkt fast wie
immer jubelnde parteimitglieder feiern
den großen führer kim jong un
der winkt bescheiden ab um dann eine
dramatische nachricht an sein volk zu
richten
selten offen spricht er die
wirtschaftsprobleme des landes an und
warnt vor einer hungersnot
ich habe mich entschlossen abtei um
einen weiteren beschwerlichen marsch zu
bitten um das volk von den problemen zu
entlasten
der ausdruck beschwerlicher marsch wird
in nordkorea verwendet um die hungersnot
in den 90er jahren zu beschreiben
millionen menschen sollen damals
gestorben sein
die ernte bilder heute täuschen
flutkatastrophen haben viele
ackerflächen zerstört
außerdem schloss nordkorea am zuge der
korona pandemie seine grenzen der
wichtige handel mit china kam zum
stillstand
trotz massiver wirtschaftssanktionen
baut kim laut einem un-bericht im
letzten jahr sein atomprogramm weiter
aus das vor kurzem testete er einen
mutmaßlichen marschflugkörper es ist
schwer die notlage nordkorea genau zu
beurteilen aber die nachrichten sind
besorgniserregend denn der drohende
wirtschaftliche kollaps macht das land
noch unberechenbarer
vor allem wenn sein führer demonstrativ
wieder die militärischen muskeln spielen
lässt
diese woche öffnete in pjöngjang eine
ausstellung mit bleistiftskizzen dort
zeichnet das land eine heile welt eine
welt die jetzt selbst der große
vorsitzende kind bedroht sieht heute in
einer woche soll der verstorbene prinz
philip auf schloss windsor beerdigt
werden
so lange gilt in großbritannien national
trauer
am mittag wurden in den vier
hauptstädten des königreichs
london/edinburgh cardiff und belfast
kanonen salven abgefeuert
ebenso von kriegsschiffen der royal navy
aus auch die titelseiten der britischen
zeitungen kennen nur ein thema und
widmen sich ausführlich dem leben von
prinz philippe und seinem vermächtnis
die fußballspiele der premier league
begann am nachmittag mit einer
schweigeminute
eben gedenken an den prinzen tja und
jetzt geht es auch zum fußball zur
fußball-bundesliga nämlichen arbeit ja
und da gab es dann wirklich
spektakuläres topspiel frankfurt besiegt
wolfsburg die eintracht ist da mit dem
erstmaligen einzug in die champions
league noch ein stück näher gekommen
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des 28
spieltags frankfurt gegen wolfsburg 4 zu
3 bayern schafft gegen union berlin nur
ein 1 1 unentschieden
herter und gladbach trennen sich 2 2
bremen unterliegt klar leipzig mit 1 zu
das abendspiel stuttgart gegen dortmund
bereits gestern besiegte bielefeld
freiburg mit 1 0 die tabelle bayern
münchen jetzt nur noch mit fünf punkten
vor leipzig wolfsburg trotz der
niederlage weiter dritter und nur noch
einen punkt dahinter frankfurt dortmund
fünfter 10 punkte entfernt von einem
champions league platz könnte aber heute
abend den abstand wieder verkürzen
sechster leverkusen siebter union berlin
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
freiburg und am tabellenende
bielefeld vorerst auf platz 15 dahinter
mainz und köln
die morgen gegeneinander spielen und
abgeschlagen schalke 04 und das
abendspiel stuttgart gegen dortmund
ausführlich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23.30 zu gast
wolfsburg-stürmer baut welches die
deutschen fußball frauen haben in
wiesbaden in einem freundschaftsspiel
australien mit 5 zu 2 besiegt vor der
begegnung wurde für die zieht das rauch
positiv auf corona getestet drei andere
dfb spielerinnen mussten dass
kontaktpersonen ebenfalls in quarantäne
auch ohne die fehlenden spielerinnen
bestimmt die deutsche elf das geschehen
schneller angriff über rechts und nüsken
die führung schon nach elf minuten
direkt abgezogen von der jungen
frankfurterinnen in ihrem zweiten
länderspiel bundes trainerin
voss-tecklenburg bekommt bis zur pause
viele weitere vergebene chancen zu sehen
anders nach dem wechsel flanke die brics
direktabnahme henrich 2 0 gegen
zunehmend hilflos ihre gegnerinnen die
gerade eingewechselte juli brand nimmt
sich ein herz
30 nach einer guten stunde beim stande
von 4 21 gelingt linda dallmann das
schönste tor des nachmittags
nachlässigkeiten in der abwehr
ermöglichten den gästen in der
schlussphase zwei treffer das 5 2 gegen
den weltranglisten-sechsten dennoch ein
starker auftritt
nur einen tag nach seiner vorlaufen
niederlage bei der ruder em in italien
ist einer weltmeister oliver zeidler
zurück auf erfolgskurs
ein eindrucksvoller start-ziel-sieg zeit
las im gelben bot heute ihren halbfinal
auf dem lago lila reese selbst
titelverteidiger sven nielsen aus
dänemark musste sich der deutschen
olympia hoffnung mit knapp einer sekunde
rückstand geschlagen geben morgen dann
das finale im einer und das zeigen wir
abschied zu nehmen livestream ebenso das
finale des deutschland achters danke
norbert und wir haben jetzt noch einen
absoluten sensationsfund für sie und
zwar diese 3000 jahre alte stadt in der
nähe des ägyptischen luxor die
archäologen staunten nicht schlecht als
sie seit september immer neue räume
alltagsgegenstände oder einen bereich
für die herstellung von sandalen
freilegten
laut dem ausgrabungsteam ist das aber
nur der anfang noch etliche geheimnisse
sollen unter dem sand schwimmer und
schon jetzt sei diese stadt der
wichtigste fund seit der entdeckung des
grabes von tutenchamun
vor ungefähr 100 jahren faszinierend
weniger faszinierend wird das wetter mal
schnee mal frühlingshaft wie das alles
zusammen passt erklärt uns gleich es den
terry
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie um viertel
nach elf zum heute-journal und uns
gibt's morgen wieder um 7 bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kaltluft die
nächste runde steht an und die kommt aus
dem norden
ja und den süden den erreicht warme luft
und die gegensätze sind sehr groß
ansonsten haben es mit regen und
teilweise schnee in den mittelgebirgen
zu tun
schauen wir uns das ganze im detail an
dem westen regnete es der regen setzte
sich allmählich richtung nordosten durch
ansonsten im norden ist es so kalt dass
es schneit im süden lockert es auf
genauso wie nach ost nennen und die
temperaturen sinken auf null grad in
schleswig-holstein also rutschgefahr
auch wegen der temperatur und im westen
um 9 grad morgen im tagesverlauf dann
viel regen im westen in den
mittelgebirgen geht das in schnee über
schnee gibt es auch richtung nordwesten
aber richtung osten zwischen oder neiße
richtung erzgebirge sonn chan und auch
im südosten deutschlands und das bei
großen temperaturunterschieden von 21
grad im osten und 4 grad ganz im
nordwesten ja am montag geht allmählich
der regen im süden schnee über ansonsten
lockert es im norden auf 3 bis 10 grad
und danach beruhigt sich das ganze
allmählich mittwoch bis 13 grad damit
ein schöner abend